[Música]
falei com muitas vezes há nada que por
isso vendo bem liga levanta aqui sonhei
com você
adam e aí olha que este campeonato bom
vocês aqui bom estou muito bem no jogo
até calouro deus é meu paulo com esse
calor que eu falei meu deus foi nessas
cidades o meia noite eu estava apanhando
bocha da minerva me leva carga muito eo
pior que tipo assim provoca muita comida
pra ela eu pensei não vou colocar menos
comida que começou a cair - mas não
quanto menos comida o voto mais que ela
caia mera tipo ponta delgada para limpá
lo aqui não tem moeda ganhou um bosta
já no começo do vídeo é pedir uma coisa
pra vocês se você é fã se você gosta
muito dos meus vídeos você admira meu
trabalho se você gosta daquilo que eu
faço que você gosta diz que eu faço e
japonês começando o vídeo clicando
gostei porque você me ajuda muito fazer
que eu divido com vocês e vocês nem toca
fica não gostei pra me ajudar pode ser é
outra coisa muito importante que você
pode fazer para ajudar o seguinte toda
vez que o vídeo só eu posso no facebook
em vídeo no o senhor quer dizer que lá
se você está nas postagens por favor
clique não curte o momento embaixo você
me ajuda também muito então assim que eu
estava aqui o facebook passa o que lá
ele deu uma louca assim não vou fazer um
vídeo sobre sexo então pedi para você e
facebook você eo twitter fizesse
perguntas sobre sexo ela perguntou eu
peguei as perguntas mais votadas no funk
mas quando você dá love porque tem muita
gente que tem muita dúvida sobre muita
coisa só que infelizmente penta e se
você vem aqui pra eu falar portarias eu
percebi ela não se pode fechar o vídeo
aí pode vazar atuais onde as terras de
tio do meu jeito que eles já estão lá
com um boi passa pela estre então vamos
à primeira pergunta do dia sousa
perguntou 'você é virgem é john harrison
perguntou como foi sua primeira vez a
carga primeira vez foi ó uma bosta eu
estava nervoso e tão nervoso negócio não
queria subir onde subiu não queria
entrar lá pô como diabetes faz aqui cara
filme pornô é uma bosta um pornô só
presto você achar que você vai fazer
aquilo que você tanto ama não faz mas
enfim é que você perguntou a primeira
vez a primeira mesma linha fast essa foi
muito porque tipo foi a primeira
experiência mesmo o primeiro protesto
que eu diga sim direto mas já a segunda
foi totalmente diferente então foi assim
a primeira primeira com a box ea segunda
formar havia odeni silva perguntou mais
importante é dar receber prazer dessa
pergunta é fácil e óbvia mais importante
a 12 isso foi um batom bonito no der
prazer estar ligado que não tem uma
segunda pena então é importante dá
prazer também agora me respondes itu vai
né
e tu receber prazer pra que diabo é que
tu vai então é importante a 12 o
alexandre cavallo perguntou o tamanho é
documento a mulher gosta de grande ou
pequeno paulo pergunta acho que até é
sobre isso que eu queria conversar com
você essa é uma das maiores dúvidas que
os homens têm toda a humanidade o fmi
agora lá dentro é tudo bem no mérito não
mas nós tem que ser grande para poder
chegar lá no final lá no fundo alcançar
o prazo eu já sei quando o negócio
prazer fosse mais lá no fundo não é
aceitável um cabo de vassoura a parada
do negócio é grande ou pequeno é só uma
coisa é impresso o cara falar com a
mulher né passei por lá e faltava chegar
lá e vai tirar a roupa e tapa na mulher
feita a nossa grande a grande causa uma
boa impressão mas na hora do vamos ver
na aliança strom pago é essa marcar com
o emanuel vital perguntou que é tulipa
mostrou um ato lícito
só que o coxa que o deixou quiróz
perguntou quem é mais safado na cama o
homem ou a mulher dele se eu tenho uma
frase que é a cara dessa pergunta que
elas nem tudo o que parece é às vezes o
cara é bom bado gigante anda todo
marreta sst 10 e fé e nadinho todo duro
velhos a fazer na direita e tvs que
aquela menina que tinha passado na praça
fala com ninguém não é por lá só pra
frente com a paciência de me falar nada
com meu filho
a ver que tanto mais que é o que mais
então estou para ver quem tem mais a
fala é tudo igual é tudo igual a maré
claro leicam perguntou qual é a melhor
posição maria clara melhor posição é
aquela que dá fazer dois ea posição que
mais dá prazer para os dois
é a típica papai e mamãe porque porque a
mulher ela sentir muito pouco prazer
internamente ela sente mais lá de fora
que o chamado território escritório
escritórios prestam de alienígena e eu
sou eleitor esquecer porque essa é a
melhor posição porque o cara ele fica
inclinado em cima da mulher do goleiro e
faz um movimento é uma roçada lá sabem
há mulheres que pra ver por fora prazer
poder e como castigo pra em qualquer
posição essa é a posição que mais traz
prazer para os dois o prefeito perguntou
como manter a virgindade fazendo sexo é
só você não dá o roda né rodrigues
seccional é por ano mas a julgar pela
sua foto do perfil pra você eu acho que
é o deixou ferreira perguntou porque
depois do sexo os homens ficam com sono
geralmente é porque a gente é que fica
com a maior parte do trabalho a que
ficou a mulher que faz o maior parte do
trabalho que quando fica com sono assim
não sei a gente sair outra vez perguntou
por que os homens gostam tanto de anal
de velhos de 70 minha querida você tem
que colocar uma coisa na sua cabeça o
homem é teimoso pra [ __ ] se tivesse
um buraco na testa
ele queria meter lá se um buraco no teu
ouvido fosse grande ele é querer meter
lá tivesse um buraco melhor costela e
queremos mantê lá tudo fosse cheio de
buraco e limitem todos os buracos e é
óbvio que é bom também é cavalo
perguntou o que você acha dessas meninas
que conhecem o carro uma noite tranquila
no mesmo dia era a minha querida isso se
chama vida porque quando a minha nova
vida e dizer não porque eu não sou assim
eu gosto de conhecer a inspeção assim aí
começa a conhecer um pouco mais sobre
ela então fez depois olha alguma coisa
protejo quanto tiver 35 anos vai fazendo
assim a guerra não queria me essa festa
não é o seguinte se guarda enquanto você
pode aproveitar suas amigas sai
aproveita sua infância
atiça avisando procurando mais tarde
essa é a realidade desculpa de jogar
isso assim as cartas na mesa como dia
camelo a bruninha freitas perguntou qual
alta mais xixi os índios viana perguntou
sérgio tem que ser a pessoa certa né
então vamos ao ponto sem atrair sua
namorada por uma noite de sexo não seria
a chance maior transação é feita pela
internet tanto no esquema não há gente
boa no vendido coelho perguntou uma dica
pra nós da classe da hora não deixar
ninguém na mão é saber que também nasceu
o que mais deixa os caras com medo antes
de a chuva guia completo é o seguinte eu
falei no começo desse vídeo vídeo pornô
é uma das coisas que mais te ilude que
você acha que vai ser o qg não é só pra
você também a china é agora você não fez
você precisa saber de uma coisa sexo é
totalmente diferente de março o assunto
totalmente diferente não tem nada a ver
porque porque machuca você pode
controlar a nossa linha só você pode
mais devagar você pode dar uma parada
para poder nessa hora você continue tá
me acreditar na hora mim não você está
ali pra dar prazer ea mulher tá aí pra
receber prazer se você estiver fazendo
direito ea mulher tivesse sentindo
prazer que ela não dá pra você ficar num
ano peguei preparei para aí vou
continuar não é assim mas se você pára
recorta o efeito do prazer já tem mulher
só chega no ápice - se você for direto
sem parar a jogada é colocar já colocou
rápido demais aí né uma leva de pessoas
e obviamente vai dizer que o ano seja
tão rápido demais não vai ter que foi
bom é confortável mas é pai pra você vai
pra então lá tem gente que como é que
ele diz o tite eu acho acho tosco isso
acho todo o amigo sempre um amigo sempre
está mais quando você tiver perto de
roswell cerveja na sua volta e sim
acidente assim coisa feia o meu deus do
céu me diz qual é o propósito de você
estar em um momento de prazer uma coisa
boa e aí você pensar na volta em saem
acidente nada ver sair cá nada e vai
fazê lo de todo mundo aí que a espera
não dizer o quê
tem que fazer preste bem atenção é o
seguinte o macho do seu saco tem um
músculo se você colocar os dedos entre
os eus apitador bola se você vai ver que
você vai sentindo esse músculo que
controla o tempo que você demora para
lançar quanto mais forte for mais tempo
vai conseguir ficar né
schumann a idéia perguntando como é que
vai fazer chegar mais forte é um músico
como qualquer outro músico se trabalhar
ele vai ficar mais forte é que faz com
que trabalha no braço se contrai os
músculos relaxam músico traz um músico
relaxa o músculo é isso como é que vai
votar em você mas naquela famosa 30 de
coco que prende e solta aprende só vai
falar mijão de boi pai você prende um
nicho para 1 57 segundos só aí quando o
negócio estiver forte lá dez horas sem
parar para o rafael tentou por que as
mulheres protegem tanto anos a bola foi
ao jogo eu quero fazer pergunta você
você tem cursos e deixa as pessoas a
enfiarem alguma coisa dentro da mina
protege pelo mesmo motivo pela seca se
gostasse está chegando e você aí falo
beleza cara vir aqui rápida e só rossi
ocupa que não pode mais sofrer perguntou
é verdade disse o pai a mãe eo bebê
leite a pessoa morre uma pergunta muito
capciosa é mentira porque porque a gente
vai vitamina de manga com leite e eu
nunca morri
quebrei um mito e aí meu deus agora a
holanda tentou quanto tempo um homem
consegue ficar sem sexo aí de repente o
cara tem cara que é tranquilo assim
feitura mais tranqüilo e parrilla 80
mais falado não aguenta chega na casa de
outro irmão para o território ter aí não
é todo mundo é igual a nada até espero
do sexo é mais gostoso com amor carranca
e todo mundo que está destinado a
assistente de se colocar uma coisa na
cabeça de vocês para as pessoas são
diferentes algumas pessoas sexo mas
gosto do amor mas por outras pessoas só
quer me perguntou o que fazer
naqueles dias achei que quando você tem
uma bicicleta águas e com um carro siena
fora de casa é como o carro quebra o que
se faz e de bicicleta 98 transa ea
menina quebra não pode mais transar que
vai fazer
continuam sendo amigos depois sexo pra
mim relação sexual a trabalha amizade
ninguém pôde se familiarizar de amizade
de verdade é que não há roupa que vai
destruir suíno no twitter adriana viver
pergunto por que a posição preferida dos
homens e quatro suplentes porque é bom
sem falar que a vista é sensato não e
natalie você vê tudo assim hdtv assim 80
pela screen que é isso aí eu pergunto
aonde vai fazer um vídeo sobre sexo ela
fala muita merda e muita criança de
assistir ea menor teria só tem o
seguinte as pessoas pesquisam as pessoas
vão atrás às vezes tem vergonha vez não
quer perguntar pro pai pra mãe às vezes
pesquisem encontra aquilo que ela vê a
chassis negócio que passa três anos
sexual só a meta é introduzir o pênis
pps correcta gente como a gente mesmo
então é isso aí então se você tiver
gostar desse vídeo eu lhe dei alguma
coisa você se divertiu por aqui
clique aqui e gostei porque não gostei e
me deixou muito feliz
de repente pela quantidade e gostei e se
tiver muito forte nesse vídeo que talvez
a gente faça parte 2 alguma coisa assim
sei depende de vocês eu queria que você
comentasse aqui em baixo ao mundo de que
você tem alguma coisa muito estranha que
você passou
enquanto se fazia ou então alguma coisa
que você quer fazer e sei lá qualquer um
que tivesse pego em baixo se eu soubesse
onde respondeu não souber de uma peça
que estava para lhe responder e é isso
aí você não está inscrito neste canal
sequer sabe mais esse canal é só ficar
inscrever-se aqui e já hebe não tiver
menos você vai saber quando é que
eliminou neste canal este canal tem
minuto da quarta feira e todos ao lado
bom é que quarta feira tem visto até
aqui no sapo tv também então é isso aí
muito obrigado e as redes sociais têm na
descrição do vídeo e quando eu gostei
porque quando curtir compartilhou e é
isso aí falou para eu saber e transa
quem é que tanto nessa [ __ ]
[Música]